okay
I don't ever normally do the 2000 clap
unless there's a showman and uh where
the cameras are and that's uh where the
spirits live
so that you you do the clap to bring out
the small the small Spirits the small
ones to help you in training
but uh I thought it looked uh nice and
you have a good energy a little bit too
Lively at the moment
but you have a good energy so I thought
I'd do it because I felt as if it was
the right thing to do but normally I
wouldn't I just bow
so depending on who follows me where
around the country or different seminars
keep a close eye because sometimes I
will clap and sometimes not
but that's the reason why you do clap is
to bring out the
the small the spirits to help you train
okay please
you could do this all your life and just
enjoy this piece
ah
if you can't see me
he doesn't know if I'm gonna attack him
hold strong
and turn
hey
this thumb
is the direction
he can hold back I don't mind it's good
for my Center
you may question what foot
step steps where you just
pick one up and put it down and let your
brain tell you that you're going around
in circles it's a
it starts off with that and then later
you'll work it out more clearly
and when you want to stop you put your
foot
across his line
when I want him to stop I will put my
foot outside that Circle to stop him
okay please try
if I want to take it out then I
because I want to keep
his shoulder
his shoulder with my side and if I'm
taller than my partner there's no good
me lowering to his shoulder
so I I keep connected
I keep connected this way
so I would do this with kinana guardi
remember quinoa is when it doesn't stop
not the speed
eight
one two
this time we step behind them rather
than in front
hey
behind
try not to look someone
becomes
all right so here comes here
and you step behind
so I
so
jump behind that's right
hey this is really
strong back leg
bent legs don't look lots of things to
put in your memory
comes here
I'm gonna jump this foot behind him
throw him over
foreign
if there is a secret please
for me
to get both feet together
this one comes
like that
you have to try and train
lots and not I'll do this side against
this
you have to train lots of times
he's passed my body now so I can just
I can just put it through
what happens is
people get here and they're off balance
their self
so they go to put this foot down it
doesn't go very deep
and they don't try
you have to go here
you have to push off the straight leg
so push off the straight leg